[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مش حرام هالوجه يكون الو هيك جسم القصه
وما فيها هي انا بدها شويه اراده
حرام يعني نحن عم نحكي كرمالك انت هيك
نازعه حالك وبكره ما بقى حدا بتطلع فيكي
هو بطعم الضيعه كلها انت بدك تاكليهم
قبل ما اعرفكم على حالي اسمها ساره خوري
عمرها 30 سنه
منها 30 سنه عم تجرب تخسر وزن لانه الوزن
صار عم باثر على صحتها من بعد ما اثر على
نظرتها لحالها
وعلى شغله وعلى كل شيء غير بحياتها وراح
اعرفكم عن حالي اسمي ساره خوري عمري 33
سنه وصرت ضعفانه 33 كيلو يعني
يعني كيلو عن كل سنه
لحالكم كيف لحظه
من انا وصغيره بجرب حلوه كنت اسمع انت
مهزبه كتير او انت ذكيه او انت شاطره بس
ولا مره سمعت كلمه انت حلوه وشوف اختي عم
بعيطوا لها حلقتنا ويقولوا لها انت كثير
حلوه ويحبوها وانا كان عطوله حسن صبري
فانا فكر انه اكيد لازم يكون حلوه تيحبوني
كبرت شوي وصلت اسمع كلام مثل مليانه
وطبوشه وصرت ارن حالي بالبنات يلي معي
بالمدرسه كان يلبسوا تنوره الا انا البس
بنطلون لانه انا جسمي مش حلو كفايه وانا
ماني حلوه كفايه مثلهن
بمراهقتي بلشت اسمع انت حلوه بس
انت حلوه بس ناصحه انت حلوه انت وقاعده بس
اذا بتوقفي الواحد بغير رايه
انت حلوه بس ما عندك انوثه لانك ناصحه
وعلى طول كنشوف هذا مش ناوي
كنشوف على طول الشباب هيك عم بلطشوا
رفقاتي عن جد حبيت شي مره شابه يلطشني
في مره قرب شب هيك لحد كنت انا ورفقاتي
انا قلت هيدي هي بلشت هيك احضر حالي انه
انا رح اتلطش هلا
وبدي هيك بدي اتكبر على شاب قرب الشاب لحد
قال لي سوري بتقولي لي رفيقتك شو اسمها
لانه مش عم ترد علي
واكيد على سهره تخرجي ما رحت لانه انا مش
حلوه كفايه لحتى اروح
بلاش شغلي يتاثر
بلشت ما اقدر اعطي رايي ما اقدر ما اقدر
اشتغل ما اقدر اظهر على طول من على طول عم
بنزوي والمسلسل الوحيد يلي مثلت فيه
اعطوني دور حبله حبله قلبي دق
سمعت قلبي ده
عطيوني دور حبله
بتوم
وعلى طول كنت اسمع انه مش ضروري نحط لها
شيتو تبين حبله ما هي حبله كفايه
وبشعك في
30 سنه عشت مع هول الافكار
وعم نبش على جواب عم نبش على طريقه اكون
حلوه فيها لحتى انحب فتت مع مجموعه روحيه
معينه
بلشت تحس فيها بالحب
صرت تحس فيها بحب الاشخاص وحس فيها بحب
اكبر بعد بس طبعا مش مصدقه انا لانه على
طول في براسي صوت هيك صار اعمق من الوعي
تبعي عم بقول لي مش ممكن حدا يحبك لانه
منك حلوه لتنحبي وما انك ضعيفه لا تنحبي
نسيت قصه حياتي
[تصفيق]
بعلم النفس ومن كتاب لكتاب
لحتى لقيت الجواب عرفت انه في شخص واحد
كان لازم يحبنا قبل ما حضن تاني يحبني
هالشخص هو انا
بلاش تحب كل جزء مني وبلاش تحب كل عمر مني
حكيت مع ساره الصغيره ساره يلي كانت عم
تاكل لحتى تحمي حالها يلي كانت عم تاكل
لانه خايفه من الضرب
حكيت مع ساره الاكبر شوي لاني عم تاكل
لانه عم تفتش على حب امها وشايفه امها عم
تبعد عنها شوي شوي
واما اكيد هي كمان كانت عم تفتش على حدا
يحبها
حكيت ما صار المراهقه يلي عمرها 16 سنه
ولا بلشت تختبر شيء اسمه نوبات هلا ما
بعرف اذا حدا مختبر هذا الشيء قبل بس هو
شي كثير بشع
طرقات قلب سريعه بتحسوا حالكم عم تغيبوا
عن الوعي او عم بتموتوا وانا بهذا اللحظه
واول مره اختبرت فيها نوبه الهلا حسيت انه
انا خلاص هذه هي اللحظه اللي بده بدي اموت
فيها وما كنت قادره اشارك حدا
حكيت مع ساره يلي عمرها 24 سنه يلي خسرت
امها بمرض
كان عم بخليها تضعف شوي شوي
لحد ما ماتت امها وزنها 36 كيلو
حكيت مع ساره
يلي كانت بهذا الوزن ومكان تقدر تتحرك
ومن بعد
علاج روحي ونفسي ومن بعد مجهود كبير ومن
بعد حبك كبير
صارت ساره هيك هيدا مش مسرع
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
هدول كلهم حكيت معهم حكيت مع كل جزء مني
وقلت لها ما بقفل زومتكلي ما بقفل زوم
تحمي حالك لانه انا حميتك وانت بامان هلا
حكيت مع ساره يلي ناطره حب قلت لها ما بقى
تاكل لتتعب بهذا الفراغ انا بحبك وانا رح
اعطيك هذا الحب
واذا ناطرين الرجيم يلي انا عملته ما عملت
رجيم سوري او هذا هو الرجيم اللي عملته هو
رجيم رسائل
لازم تجربوها على فكره يلي بحب
وساره يلي بهذا الوزن
وحكيت معها اكيد هي وعم تمثل قلت لها
ميرسي انك مثلتي رغم كل شي ميرسي انه
حققتيه لحلمه رغم كل المصاعب
ساره بهذا الوزن بعثت لها رساله قلت لها
جمله وحده قلت لها انت قويه كتير لانك
قطعتي كل هوله وبقيتي واقفه على رجليك
وبقيتي عم تكفي واكيد هلا بتستاهل تعيشي
بفرح واكيد بتستاهل تظهري من هذا الخوف
واكيد انت حلوه كفايه ماشي
[تصفيق]